nettoyer tout ce que ses propriétaires
peuvent faire en ce premier jour de
confinement le coeur n'y est pas
l'incertitude plombent leur moral ils ne
veulent pas en parler à la caméra dans
les rues autour les parisiens feront
leur courses s'est permis et tous leurs
marques
c'est plus animées qu'on prête pour
l'instant je vois pas tellement de
différence avec un autre jour
appartenait et qu'elle fait sans fermer
mais c'est tout un peu perdu mais dans
l'ensemble je trouve ça quand même
beaucoup plus joyeux que la première
fois il ya plus de monde dans les rues
et moi un sentiment d'être un peu perdu
le confinement à léger mais bien réel il
faut parfois justifié ses déplacements
aux policiers
les rideaux sont baissés les rues sont
occupés mais les bouchons de circulation
ont disparu la liste des secteurs
d'activité qui peuvent fonctionner
malgré le confinement est plus longue qu
au printemps
malgré cela l'incertitude économique
ajoute à l'incertitude sanitaires donc
on essaie de travailler au maximum pour
novembre décent pour attraper ce qu'on
sait qu'on va tous aller en confinement
total ans parce que la pandémie fait que
vous montez
peut continuer jusqu'à dimanche c'est
très long terme et donc en serre et la
vente à emporter est permise dans les
librairies il faut commander à l'avancé
par internet
c'est ce que les français appellent le
click and collect est alors le click and
collect et tout ce qu'on ce qu'on va
faire
évidemment ne remplace pas un magasin
ouvert d'un point vue activités donc on
s'interdit pas de faire appel au chômage
partiel en fonction des jours qui
viennent
paris fonctionne donc au ralenti c'est
russie animé se vide rapidement en fin
de journée après tout il n'y a rien
d'autre à faire que de rentrer à la
maison ici avec du mans baron
radio-canada paris